You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye and health conditions at early stages. To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an
OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers.capsavers. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi.
Let's tell everybody what we're doing today because this is exciting. I'm so excited about it. We watched the Hot Girl Peacock Superfan episode. So much extra stuff. So much extra stuff. You know, we went into our mailbag and you all suggested that we watch and break down some of these Peacock Superfan. episodes. There are some people who don't even know these exist. I know. And they're so good. They are such a labor of love of our dear friend Dave Rogers. And I'm so glad we're finally watching them.
Yeah. So you know, we broke down Hot Girl before in our original rewatch, but there are added scenes. And we also found so many more things that we could talk about. Well, Jenna, are you going to do a summary? Are you doing fast facts? What's happening? I really sad. with that question, Angela, in planning this episode. Yeah. I'm going to do a title. Okay. Is it hot girl?
Just curious. I'm going to say this. Okay. Season one, episode six. All accurate. Written by Mindy Kaling. Directed by Amy Heckerling. Yes.
I'm going to give you a summary. Okay. I'm not going to give you any fast facts, though. Okay. I'm not going to, you know. I have to decide at a certain point. You've drawn a line. And it ends here.
Okay. All right. You heard it. But here's your summary because I couldn't give that up. Okay. The appearance of an attractive purse saleswoman sparks a romantic rivalry between Michael, Dwight, and Jim and causes Pam to examine her own feelings. Okay. Okay.
Now, I'm not going to leave you hanging here in the Top of Show. We did promise we would give Top of Show shares, and I've got a big one for you. Okay. In our original breakdown of this episode, we mentioned that Amy Adams, who stars as the purse girl, Katie, was Mindy Kaling's first choice for the role. But what we didn't share was that Amy Adams was not the first person cast in the role. Nope. We originally shot Hot Girl. for an entire day with a completely different actress in the role of Katie.
And unfortunately, she just wasn't quite right for the role. They had to let her go. We replaced her with Amy. And it's so funny because in our original breakdown, we talk about how when Amy was shooting with us, she told us a story about how she had just been fired from a job when we were all on set together. It's such a common thing in the business. it's almost like a rite of passage.
It is. And I actually wrote about it in my book, the actor's life, because while I was writing my book, I got fired from a show and I share all about it in my book. But I also did some research and I thought you might enjoy some of these tidbits. Okay. For example, did you know that Lisa Kudrow was originally cast as Roz in the pilot for Frazier? No. Mm-hmm.
Yes. And Ray Romano was originally cast as the handyman in news radio. Really? And he was let go. And Bob Odenkirk was supposed to play Nathan on Will & Grace, but he was let go and replaced with Woody Harrelson. Mm-hmm. Well, you know, it just sometimes comes down to so many things that are outside your control. Mm-hmm.
And I remember when Amy came on the set, she was so seamlessly Katie. Yeah. She improvises a lot, you guys. We'll get to it. But a lot of her improvs make it in. She just knew who this woman was. Well, Allison Jones shared with us that Amy Adams was everybody's first choice for Katie the purse girl. But there was this concern that Amy and I looked too similar. And I guess one of the writers even said, I'm sorry, we can't cast her. She's like Jenna 2.0. And so they got cold feet and they cast someone else. But when it didn't. work out, they decided to cast Amy and just lean into the fact that she and I looked similar because that wasn't the idea behind the role at first. That was not part of the conception of Katie the purse girl. And then that is why they added that line. She's like Pam 6.0, which is just so amazing because that writer had said it up in the writer's room. Yeah. Well, Jenna, I have a little something to share at Top of Show. Please. So, You know, I went back to the DVDs for this episode to rewatch the original and compare it to the superfan episode.
And I forgot how much the DVDs themselves evolved as the show went on, just in what they included and the look of them. For example, in this season one disc, when you click on an episode, there is a picture and an episode summary. So for Hot Girl on the screen, there's a picture of Dwight and Katie in the conference room. And then on what looks like to be like a lined piece of notebook paper is the following. Is this their summary? Yes. Oh. What?
That's probably going to be better than that. No, it's not. Stop it. Okay. Stop that. This is what it says. Hot Girl Air Date, semicolon, 4-2605. Okay.
And then it says episode summary. The blundering men of Dundermifflin vie for the attention of an attractive woman who appears at the office trying to sell purses. Oh, I think my summary was better. Well, actually. Anyway, there you go. Worried for nothing. There you go.
That is what it says about this episode on the original DVDs. Well, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we will break down this super fan episode of Hot Girl. And we have lots of fun new stuff. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not. not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Yeah. Not a totally new you, but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine.
Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down. What might be holding you back. You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Because those really just add up. And they're going to be just fine. Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. BetterHelp therapists can help.
With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, h-elp.com slash office ladies. We are back and we kick things off with the same scene you would have seen in the broadcast episode. Michael is sticking some pencils in his computer keyboard.
He looks like he's, I don't know, bored. He's not working. Nope. And then you come to realize Jan is on speakerphone. Yeah. She and Alan have created a. an incentive program to increase sales. And at the end of the month, Michael can reward the top seller in the office with a prize worth up to $1,000. Yeah. And he says, do I get to decide what that $1,000
is spent on? And she's like, sure. Yeah. And he's like, Jan. Mistake. Yes. And he also wants to know, you know, if you're not still currently in sales, but maybe if you used to be in sale. And she's like, No, Michael, you're not eligible to win. And then next up, we have an added scene, which is so good. Oh, my gosh. I loved it so much. We have Amy Adams arriving in the office as Katie. Yes, Jenna, I thought we should hear how it was described in the shooting draft.
Great. Interior Office Open Area Day. Meredith is working on a crossword. We hear the door open and Meredith is working on a crossword. Yes, what it says. we hear the door open and whip over to catch Katie, an attractive young woman, enters the office and approaches Pam. When we pan back, we see the heads of men in the office perk up to check her out.
Katie is showing Angela some purses from a big duffel. And you guys, the supersized episode shows all the men stopping to look over. I took a screen grab. Literally all the dudes have made some reason to be in the bullpen in the back of the scene. Creed is standing right by the conference room door. Kevin is by the supply shelf. Ryan is next to Phyllis. Toby is by the water cooler. Stanley is really leaning up to look from his desk. Oscar is down on one knee digging through a box by Dwight's desk. Jim is at his desk. And Devin is on his knees at the end of Stanley and Phyllis's desk. All these dudes are watching Katie at front reception as she is trying to sell Pam and Angela. These, these ladies, little purses. At one point, she holds up this little red purse to Pam, and she's like, this color looks really good on you. This is really great for you. Lady, that's the color you say looks really good on me. It made me laugh out loud. You do look really good in that color.
So here's the thing. I thought we should hear this scene. Yeah. It's really fun. And Amy Adams, she's selling stuff. All right, let's listen. Hi. Hi. Hi. How are you? Okay. Good. I'm Kate. Hi. Hi. Nice to meet you. What's your name? Pam? Hi, nice to meet you, Pam. Let me ask you a question. Do you read a lot of fashion magazines? Because you look really fashion forward. And I just wanted to let you know, hi, how are you? I have a great opportunity today to get in on some of the newest styles. Because I know with your working hours, you don't really probably have a chance to go to the mall very often. So what I have to offer you today is some excellent purses. And if I could just have a space to set up,
maybe show you what I have and some of your other um here feel that um yeah it really brightens you yeah do you think that gives her a nice color uh i don't um no i really it really suits you um i've got uh faux leather i have some really great fakes you wouldn't even be able to tell the difference i don't want to just like all the movie stars i don't want to interrupt you um sorry um we don't usually allow solicitors in the office well i'm actually uh selling purses right i i'm No, that's what I mean. I can't, I'm just the receptionist. I can't authorize you to, like, come in and set up or anything.
Okay, is there somebody that I could talk to? Like, who would authorize? Is that you? I love it. She turns to you, Angela. She's like, who would authorize? Is that you? It's like, you're like, no.
No. My favorite line is when she says, I have some really great fakes. You won't even be able to tell the difference. Yes. All right. Fan question from Jenna F in Los Angeles. Jenna F remembers that a lot of this scene was improvised. Angela, can you confirm?
Absolutely can confirm. Literally, all it says in the shooting draft is that Katie is showing Angela some purses from a big duffel. And then Pam does go to Michael's office. Yeah. And the only dialogue that is scripted is this. Katie's showing Angela some purses from a big duffel says, that one is hand embroidered. Angela says there's a smudge on it. And then that's when Pam and Michael entered Dwight tagging along behind them.
So Amy Adams really improvised a lot at that front reception. And she was so good as Katie. So good. Also, lady, did you hear how she introduces herself? No, what did she say? I'm Kate. Oh, you know what? It's so funny.
I thought I caught that when I was watching it. Yeah. And then when Michael walks up, she says, I'm Katie. And here's my fan theory. Ready? Okay. She doesn't want Michael to know her real name. She already has realized.
She sussed it out. When he's like Cox in the Hint House, she's like, I'm not telling him my real name. Well, we should back up a second because we skipped a scene, which is Dwight and Michael are in Michael's office. And they are brainstorming about what motivates people the most. Yeah. What's an incentive? Yes, because he's going to have to motivate the sales team to win this prize. At three minutes and 15 seconds, Dwight is hanging out over Michael's shoulder in that traditional spot.
However, did you notice the credenza is missing? Yes. There's no credenza yet in Michael's office in season one. Not only that, there is a picture behind Dwight of Mount Rushmore. Yeah. Like with an American flag, that wasn't there. Yeah, I noticed going back again, I really saw how this was our real building. Yes. This wasn't our set yet.
Well, I also want to note that Dwight is not wearing a mustard shirt in this episode. Oh, wow, I didn't catch that. That was kind of a good catch. That is a good catch. Well, like you said, Michael's going to get a glimpse of Katie through the blinds, and he's going to decide he does want to speak with her. Yeah. And he's going to go out, and he's going to tell her she can have the conference room. And then Pam says, but HR has a meeting in there. Oh, my gosh.
Michael says, you know what, give them the hallway with chairs. I mean, it's just ridiculous. Yeah, and in this moment, Michael's like, well, you know, decisiveness is one of the keys to being a successful businessman. Read that and small businessman. And then he has this really funny talking head where he says all the things that he reads, right? USA Today, American Way. He loves the in-flight magazine. And we talked about this in our original breakdown, but lady, if you can believe it, I have more to tell you about American Way magazine. I love in-flight magazines. I do too. And I'm sad a lot of airlines don't have them anymore.
That's what I was going to share. Oh. American Way magazine has been retired. Oh no. Yeah. According to an article in USA Today from June 2021, Dana Lawrence, American Airlines Managing Director of Global Brand Marketing said airlines are eliminating magazines due in large part to travelers changing tastes for in-flight
entertainment since the introduction of Wi-Fi on planes. Oh. But then I got into the history of the American Way magazine. Is this going to make me more sad? I don't know. I found it fascinating. It started as a 22-page booklet called The American Way in 1966, and it was just an annual publication. And in the first issue, flight attendants were called stewardesses, and business travelers were pitched family fairs, offering half-priced tickets for your wife. It was like so madmen,
this whole era. But then it moved to a monthly magazine, and American Way is very proud that they've had a few pop culture moments. They called them out in this article specifically the fact that Michael Scott played by Steve Correll bragged that he subscribed to it. They mentioned that he has that line where he says, there's some great articles in there. They did a great profile last month of Doris Roberts and where she likes to eat in Phoenix. I loved it.
American Way said they did feature an article with Terry Bradshaw and where he likes to eat in Phoenix. So if you want to look that up, you can at least find that out. And then did you know that 12 years later, our very own Mindy Kaling was on the, cover of American Way magazine. She tweeted about it. She said, I'm proud to grace the cover of Michael Scott's favorite magazine American Way. That's so funny. Well, I have to go find that because I want to read it.
Well, by 2021, Delta, Southwest, and United had also retired their in-flight magazines, but United decided to bring their hemispheres magazine back in digital form. Virgin Atlantic has also brought their magazine back online. You all know, we discussed the first time we broke this down, how I wrote an article about winning the poker tournament in Scotland for Hemisphere's Magazine. And I thought I would share an update. Okay. My family went back to Scotland in 2022. We returned to the same pub, the Wally Doug, this time with your kids. Yep. There was no poker tournament. We wanted there to be so bad. We were like, guys, listen, if we get there and there's a poker tournament, buckle in because mom's going to enter again. This has become like family
lore. Remember when mom won the poker tournament in Scotland at midnight? Yeah. But there was no poker tournament, but when we got there, the bartender was like, oh my gosh, you're that girl who from the TV show that won the poker tournament here. And I was like, yes. And it had become like, she said, we get all these American tourists who come here now because you told that story. But it was sweet. We took a photo with our kids. And now on our shelf, we have the photo of me and Lee from our first trip and then a photo with the kids.
So cute. Well, now Michael is going to get Katie all set up in the conference room. And there is a moment in the scene. It makes me laugh every time I see this episode. What is it? You know, it's when Michael is telling. Katie, look, I'm just right next door. I mean, there used to be a window here. There's not anymore, but I'll be right there, you know? Yeah. So I was like, why does he mention that window?
Is there more in the shooting draft about the fact that there was a window? This is how it reads in the shooting draft. Michael says to Katie, and this is my conference room. Make yourself at home. I'm right on the other side of the wall. Then there is this direction. Whistfully, Michael looks at the wall. There used to be a window there. He wraps on the wall. Anyway, that's where I'll be. So I'm like, what is the backstory about this? I emailed Mindy.
She did not email me back. No kidding. I was like, Mindy, I included the whole shooting draft description. I was like, please tell me there was a bigger story about this window. Poor Mindy. She's actually traveling. It's not her fault. We're going to see her for dinner soon.
We're going to see her for dinner. And she's going to be like, ang, I was on a plane. I couldn't want. Sorry. But I mean, he's wistfully looking at the wall. Oh, my gosh. I think here's my theory that there was a window there, but he would get distracted by the conference room. If there was anything happening, he would like peer in. And so they were like, nope, Jan was like no more window. So Jan took it out. I think Jan took it out. Who took it out is my question. I think did Toby take it out? Is this one of the reasons why Michael hates Toby? I think there. There were complaints about Michael in the window during the conference room meetings.
And I think corporate took it out. Well, this scene of him watching Katie, like, unpack her purses and he's just lingering. Oh, man. It's a little expanded from the original. There's just a lot more of him awkwardly watching her and asking if there's anything he can do to help, you know, until she's finally like, a cup of coffee would be great. And then he's like, I knew it. I knew it. The bucks.
You're another addict. She's like, what are you talking about? He's so excited to get her this cup of coffee. And then there's a new talking head from Michael where he says, it's probably not charming to say so, but people find him charming. There's a whole runner of Michael in this episode talking about just what a catch he is, how charming he is. It's all of these extra talking heads. We're going to point them out. And then there's this great scene between Kevin and Pam.
We talked about this when we originally watched where Kevin is just basically, saying the purse girl is prettier than Pam. And Pam's like, that's rude. Yes, we talked about how I kept breaking when we were shooting this. I can see you breaking. Now we are coming to something I am so excited about. You know, Jenna, how many times if we watch the show now, but when you come across something new, it is still so fun. Yeah. There is the scene. I have so many questions about the scene. Okay. Remember how Pam said there was an A.R. meeting in the conference room and Michael says move them to the hallway and give them chairs. Well, here it is.
This is an added scene. I think this hallway is three feet wide. It is so narrow. It just fits the chairs, basically. And it's Kelly, Creed, Meredith, Toby, Devin and Luanne. They are smushed into this tiny space. They have cups of coffee, a plate of pastries, lots of papers, a big whiteboard that keeps falling and they're trying to hold it.
It's so funny. And I went to the shooting draft to see what it said about this scene. and it's not in there. It's not in the shooting draft. And it's not in the candy bag alts. So I don't know if there were some last minute pages that flew in, but it's not in the shooting draft. Well, what's interesting is that this is the first and only time we see this full hallway on the show. It was the hallway that goes behind the back window of the conference room.
To get to it, you would go through that door next to the storage shelf. and like go to the left. Right. Okay. So the storage supply shelf where Kevin was standing. Yep. There's the door to the left. You go through that door.
And then that's where that hallway was. And this was a real thing in this real building. But it was really weird because it was like there was a window at the end of the conference room, but it just went to this hallway. And then on the other wall of the hallway were a couple of windows that actually went outside. Okay. I don't know what this.
hallway was four. It made no sense. It made no sense. It's like where the hallway, it's where Dwight, you know, lit the fire. Yes, that's right. But that was after we had recreated it on our set. We recreated part of this hallway. But in that episode, which is stress relief when Dwight starts the fire in the trash can, you only see the right corner. You never see this view behind the conference room again. So, when we were watching the final episodes of the show and I became very curious about where does this door go? And I wrote Dave Rogers and I said, where does that door go by the storage shelf? Yeah, what's the story? What happens if you turn left? We know what happens. Right.
You get to our hair and makeup stations and you get to where we would eat lunch. But I'm like, where in the world of this building of this show did we think that went? And Dave Rogers, we joke about it, he sent me back a dissertation on all the hallways of Dunder Mifflin. Yes, yes. Are you about to share Dave Rogers' dissertation on hallways? I am. Oh, my God, I'm getting comfortable.
I can't wait. So, Dave shared with me that there are a lot of Dunder Mifflin floor plans that were made by fans that try to explain where all of the doors and hallways go. Okay. In our world. Most of those show this hallway as leading to a set of stairs. So you know that door that it's at the end past the break room? You know how?
Yes, yes, right? Most of the fan theories, they have drawn a set of stairs that you can get to from either that door by the break room or a door at the end of the little hallway, okay? But there was no door at the end of this hallway. And this superfan scene must blow that out the window. Yes. Because you see it. Yes. Is that a phrase blow it out the window? Then I just make that up. Did I do one of my things? I don't think it is a phrase. It's definitely not a phrase. What is it? Does it blow it wide open? I don't know. I'm saying it blows this theory away. Angela, are you thinking? blow it out of the water? Does it blow it out of the water? Maybe. It also blows it out the window.
I'm trying to imagine like when you would do that. You'd be like, you know what? I'm going to take that and I'm going to blow it out the window. Oh, well, I don't know. It does. If you need to clear a room of smoke, you might open a window and blow it out of the window. I don't know. Anyway, I'm sorry. Go ahead. Well, I was going to say, in reality, both of those doors led to a big storage closet, which is where I believe props would keep our props. But in the world of Dunder Mifflin, we created our own Dunder Mifflin floor plan because we had to have a sense of where did these things go in the fictional world. And even on the Dunder Mifflin floor plan, we had to have a sense of, floor plan, this hallway goes nowhere.
Oh, no. It goes to nothing. On our official floor plan, we do show that the door by the break room does lead to a fictional staircase. And I think that is the staircase that would go to the spot where we saw Pam crying on the bench when Dwight comforts her. Which was the side of the warehouse. Yeah.
So that door by the break room, I believe, would take you down to the bench. that part of the building. And then also in our like Dunder Mifflin lobby elevator area, there is a staircase that would lead you down to caffeine corner. Okay. Okay. But my one question when looking at all these floor plans was, where is that long hallway that Michael is always running down that connects between those two stairwells? Oh, the writer's hallway? Yeah, we know it was the writer's hallway, but like where? Because there's windows.
Yeah. So where is that? I don't know. And why wouldn't HR go there? It's so much room here. I don't know. I mean, why didn't they go to the break room? Why didn't they go to so many places?
That's true. The kitchen. Yes. Also, looking at this floor plan, there is another door that we, we never reveal where it goes or what it is. It leads to nowhere. And that is the door in the annex by Kelly's desk. Yes. The door by accounting, we eventually reveal is a storage locker where the dock crew keeps their stuff. And where Jim and Pam hooked up once. Yeah. But we never see behind the door in the annex. The door by Kelly's desk in the annex.
As you would walk in and out of it, it went to our bathrooms. It was a back way to the bathrooms in the real world. And there was a red paintbrush, remember? It was like a little piece of art that sat on top of the shelf. It was like a, it looked like a paintbrush, but it was painting a streak of red, but it was like a little sculpture. Oh, yeah. Do you remember it? Oh, yeah.
Yeah. That was the weirdest thing. I know. I don't know why. I just remembered that. I don't know. Well, anyway, there it is, everybody. That was the hallways.
The dissertation on hallways and doorways. I was talking to Paul Lieberstein recently, and he pointed out that none of the windows of our interior set match the windows of our exterior building. And it said it's always driven him crazy. And fans never talk about it. Yes, that's right. We got in a whole conversation with him about this. It's actually a pet peeve of his. when you look at the Dundra Mifflin building from the parking lot, that the windows don't match
when you're inside looking out. He said there's all these floor plans and people worry about the hallways and the doors, but no one talks about the windows. Blow it out the window, Paul. Blow it out the window. Now we have the scene between Kevin and Dwight. You know, in the original, they're just sort of like sipping. It looks like water.
Maybe they're by the water cooler in the bullpen and they're watching Katie. and they don't have dialogue. But in the superfan episode, the full scene is there. And they're looking at her and they're trying to figure out, is she local, is she from Scranton or is she foreign? You know, would they have known her? And they're sort of, you know, they're ogling her. Is that the right word? Yes, I believe so. Okay. Well, I want you to know something. In the shooting draft, this scene was actually between Jim and Dwight. Not Dwight and Kevin. Really? Yeah. You sort of see that Jim is behind them and he doesn't say much. Well, in the shooting draft, it actually starts with Jim and Dwight, and I want to read it to you. Dwight stares at Katie and flosses. He examines the bits of
food on his floss closely. Jim says, that's more of a bathroom activity, isn't it? Dwight says, not enough natural light in the bathroom. And then it goes into the scene of them watching Katie. But Dwight is flossing his teeth in the bullpen. Isn't that so gross? You know, I'm glad that was cut from both the original and the superfan. I don't think I ever need to see that. It's so gross. Well, now Dwight is going to have a talking head. This was also in the original episode where he just talks about how the purse girl like hits everything on his list. Yep. We talked about this scene because it has the very famous line that Shrews produce very thirsty babies. Dwight doesn't need the boobs for him, though. They're for his babies. For his babies. Yeah. That's why he likes her boobs. That's right.
I thought the angle of this talking head was very interesting. He's inside the conference room, but he doesn't have Stanley's desk behind him. Nope. It's actually like he's sitting almost right by the door to the conference room, which is closed. And over his shoulder, you can see Jim. You can see Creed at the copier. Leanne crosses behind him. I mean, so much activity. So much activity, but this is the early days. We did lots of crosses and back and forths. We now have a new scene. Dwight is going to go into the conference room and try his best to flirt with Katie. He's going to look at her purses. In the script, the scene was set up like this. Dwight walks over to Katie without his glasses on. He holds up a purse very close to his eyes. He looks at the person says it's really well made. Good stitching. Excellent fabric. It was not scripted for Rain to then bat the purse back and forth around as Dwight. He improvised that.
And I want you to go to eight minutes and 23 seconds because you can see Rain starting to break at himself. He's laughing at his own bit. I love that. Well, behind Katie's shoulder, we have the Dunder Mifflin calendar blitz. Yeah. It's this whiteboard and it looks like a sales chart. Maybe this is where we're figuring out who's going to win this incentive at the end of the day. And the names on it were very curious to me.
Oh. They were Jim, Dwight, Stanley, Phyllis, Andy. Andy? Yes. Andy. Roger. Who's Roger? And Michelle with one L.
Who the hell are Roger and Michelle? I don't know. Oh, my God. I'm not sure. These super fan episodes are messing with my head. Well, the scene continues here now. Dwight is asking Katie about a specific purse. He's like, you sell a lot of these.
She says, yes, it's very popular. He then says, is it waterproof? And she responds, I'm not sure. It's faux snake skin. And then Dwight says, snakes are waterproof, so I'm betting that it is waterproof. But it's faux snakes. I know. Also, snake skin, it's not waterproof.
It's not? No. Did you look it up? I did look it up. I love that. Snakes are not waterproof, but their skin permeability can change to help them retain water. That's according to the internet, people. Well, he also has a line where he asks her if she knows the difference between a snake and an eel.
And if not, he can look it up. I looked up the difference between a snake and an eel. Well, an eel is ocean, right? It's saltwater animal. Well, Angela, according to Americanoceans.org, there are several differences between snakes and eels. Should we start with their habitat? Yes, I can tell you I swam up right on a Moray eel one time, face to face. How was that?
A little scary. Yeah. Well, eels can live in both freshwater or saltwater. In fact, the European eel migrates from freshwater to saltwater to breed. However, snakes are found mostly on land. But in a variety of habitats like deserts, forests, and swamps. Both snakes and eels lack pectoral fins and have scales, but eels have a slimy skin, whereas snakes have dry scaly skin. Eels have gills, snakes have lungs.
Eels have a tail fin that runs the length of their body, but snakes have no tail. Also, diet, most eels are coniferous, and they eat fish and crustaceans and worms. snakes are also carnivorous and eat things like rodents, birds, and other reptiles. I mean, I've got more. Do you want to hear about their reproductive cycles? I don't know. Well, buckle in because I'm going to tell you. I don't know if I want to know how they do it.
Eels lay their eggs in the ocean and the larvae drift back to freshwater environments. Snakes lay eggs or give birth to live young. So different. I knew that snakes laid eggs. Well, I think it's very different. Yeah. Snakes and eels are not closely related is the bottom line. Snakes are reptiles, eels are fish.
They belong to totally different classes of animals. So what's the moral here? You can look like something else but not have anything in common with it. Yeah, that's the moral. That's the moral of that tipta. That's why I did it. Because I wanted to make that. I wanted everyone to know that you go on something.
What is going on? I think what's going on. We've been here for six hours. Oh, you guys, we tried to do a double recording today, and this is what happens. Oh, no. Oh, gosh, I have mascara all over me. This is what you get. This is what you get.
Double record day. Loop de doo. Well, that's the moral of the story. I don't know what you do with them. That you look like the same thing as something, but you're really different. That's, everyone, take that into your weekend. Oh, my gosh. If you meet a set of twins, they might look very similar.
But they're not. They're different people. And the next time you encounter a set of twins, you're going to remember this podcast and the moral of the story. And you're going to say one's an eel and one's a snake. Exactly. Exactly. They look the same, but they're different. But also, I want to say something.
But also, snakes and eels don't even look that much alike. They're both like. I don't know long. They're both long and I guess they don't have feet. They know, yeah. All right. We should move on. We should.
Katie says, Oh, no. Guys, can we even finish this episode? This is off the rails. Oh, I was going to say it. This is out the window. This is totally gone out the window. What?
I don't know. It said, this is something that was not funny until we talked about your deep dive. Anyway, Katie says, you're really into reptiles, huh? And Dwight says, my belt is made of alligator. Then he pulls his shirt up. He's going to show off this belt. And that's when Michael comes in. And I would like to point something out.
Michael is going to have a runner in this episode. I didn't share this before of some seriously snarky behavior. Oh, Michael Snark. Michael Snark. His snarky behavior is going to be pointing out what he thinks are people's shortcomings so that they seem inferior and so that Katie will like him. So when he walks in, he says to Dwight, wear your glasses. And then he says to Katie, he wears glasses. Snark. Yeah. There's going to be more. Now Michael is going to offer to give Katie a tour of the office and he tells Ryan to watch her purses. Yeah. She doesn't want to go though. She's like my purses. He's like, they're fine. Yeah. Then we have a new Dwight talking. head. It's a classic. This is some classic Dwight here where he describes his ideal woman. Oh, yeah. You know, his ideal woman would be Koniko Taka, whose parents were assassinated and she was taken in by a wealthy, cruel businessman. But then she practiced a keto for years. Yes, to one day
secretly avenge her parents' deaths. This is who Dwight wants. Yes. Now Michael is giving Katie the tour, they're walking through the kitchen. I have a few background catches I missed the first time around. Same, same. Is yours the dry erase board that says please clean up? And it also says groceries. 10 minutes, 10 seconds. Yes, it is on the wall and it is right by the door that leads to the bullpen. At 10 minutes and 13 seconds, why is Oscar taking a phone call by the bathroom door? He is seated in a chair next to the door to the men's bathroom. There are so many other places to take a phone call. Why would you sit there? Well, I guess so that Michael can walk by and make fun of his name. I guess so. He's also sitting under a sign that says, now hiring friendly people with
smiles. Also, there's another sign by Oscar. It's another all-hands meeting. You know that all-hands meeting that's been up by Pam's desk this whole first season, it's on Saturday. No date. Just Saturday. It's a lot of meetings. Pam has a lot of a talking head where she says she likes having Katie around because it's another person for Michael to interact with. Now we've got a couple of new moments. We see Kelly trying to pick out a purse and Ryan is sort of now, I guess, in the role of salesperson. I went to the shooting draft because I was like, what is happening? Yeah. It said this. There is a shot of Ryan efficiently selling Kelly a purse. Oh, I have two things to say. Is this our very first sign that Ryan is a con man?
Oh. He's so shady. He's selling purses that aren't his. I bet if she gave him money he might pocket it. I think you're right. And then also this is our first moment of Kelly and Ryan. And it's so weird because I wonder if this happens to people when they're rewatching the show. I know what's going to happen with Kelly and Ryan. And by the way, Kelly right now is still old Kelly. She's not full Mindy yet. And so I'm like, okay, the purse she picked up is leading towards. full Mindy. Yeah. But she's still kind of dressed like old Kelly. Yeah. And I don't think there's any flirtation here. In fact, at the end of this episode, Dwight is going to give Kelly a purse, almost like hinting that there could be romance there. Yeah.
All the romances are off. And I'm a little confused because I know too much. It's so early. But when you look at this moment, one of Kelly's very first interactions with Ryan in the documentary, is him being dishonest with her. Yes. When we get to our episode on All About Ryan Howard, I think we're going to have, we'll really track his, what would you call that? Deception.
Yes. All right. Now we have another new scene, Angela, that you pointed out in our All About Michael Scott episode. Michael is continuing to give Katie a tour of the office. Yeah. He says, thank you, Al Gore for the internet. And he can't believe that you couldn't send messages electronically 10 years ago. And Katie's like, you could.
And he's like, fine, 20 years ago. Still pretty cool. Now Michael is going to introduce Katie to Toby. And they kind of hit it off. Yeah. Toby notices that she has a Bishop O'Hara ring. And he's like, oh, my God, did you go there? And she's like, yeah.
And he's like, I went there. And they're starting to bond. And of course, Michael has to cut it off. Yeah. this is another Michael Snarky moment. I want to point out something. In our initial breakdown of this, I share that there's a lot more in deleted scenes of Michael being snarky
about Toby's divorce. And lady, they didn't even include them all in the superfan episode. Really? Uh-huh. There's actually more in deleted scenes on the DVD. We never played it, and I think we should hear it. Yeah. Yeah, me too.
Cool. What, you were you there? 89. Toby's divorced. God, that's hard. That really ripped you up. She got the kids, right? That'll damage you. Sorry, man. That's a... Right a bad one. How much you're paying her? You can't even afford anything now, right?
You're all right though, right? Don't ask me for a raise! Oh, cup of soup's a good idea though. That'll... That's a good budgetary thing to do. Well, they're good snacks. are good food, good meals, good lunch. Ramen noodles are good, too. You're still sleeping in the car? No.
Because he slept in the car a couple times. Still. Are you still taking the antidepressants? This is a good idea. That'll help. It'll help, man. I'm going to go back to my table. Okay.
I'll see you in a bit. See in a bit. Michael. Michael Snark. Yeah. Yeah. And we do notice on Toby's desk there is a cup of soup. There's also a piggy bank that just says bread, cash money.
Okay. And there is a picture of a red Jeep on the wall next to him. Is this Toby's dream car? I don't know. That's a good question. Did she get the Jeep and the divorce? Sounds like she got everything. Mm-hmm.
Well, now we are going to go into the kitchen. Roy, Jim, and Pam are eating lunch. And Roy just keeps going on and on about how attractive Katie is. And we talked a lot about this in our last breakdown. You know, Pam is seated in between Roy and Jim. And Roy is like, I don't understand why you don't go for her helper, you know? If we weren't dating, I'd be all over that. And Pam's like, we're not dating.
We're engaged. She storms out of the kitchen. Here's something we did not talk about in our last breakdown. I have something as well. Is it at 12 minutes and 52 seconds? No. At the end of the scene. No.
I'll let you go first then. Mine's at the very end of the scene. It's a button at the end of the scene. Well, first of all, at the very top, Roy, and I did not catch this the first time, calls Jim Jimmy. He says, hey, Jimmy, what do you think of that little purse girl, huh? And I'm like, oh my gosh, this made me think of another fan theory, which is, Jimmy is what you call someone when you grow up with them. Did Roy and Jim know each other?
Like in elementary school? Did they grow up together? Was Jim called Jimmy when he was little? Oh, wow. I don't know. And that makes it even more layered that Roy got Pam. But that would mean that Pam knew Jim growing up? I don't know.
Where is Jim from originally? How long has Pam known Roy? Does Jim's family live in town? Do his brothers and parents live? live in town? Do we know? Their house was in town with the clown. Oh yeah, that's right. So they did. But how long has Pam known Roy? I mean, in my backstory, Pam and Roy at least went to high school together. Well, Roy and Jimmy might have gone to elementary school together. That's crazy. It's my fan theory. Okay, what was your thing?
Well, I'm just as excited about this, but at 12 minutes, and 52 seconds. Jim John is eating carrots. Oh, yes. I saw that. I think this is the first Jim John carrot eating. It starts so early. So early.
He has a sandwich and carrots. Pam had a salad and a juice box. Hmm. Adorable. And Roy has pizza. Jim has a talking head now where he just talks about like, hey, you know, Pam and I are good buddies. She comes to me with her problems like work or Roy, and those are pretty much her two problems. Well, now Dwight and Jim are watching Katie from their desks.
And Jim is really going to mess with Dwight. You know, he's saying she'd be perfect for you. And Dwight says, well, she's been talking to Michael a lot. And then I really loved this little couplet of dialogue. Jim says, so what? You're assistant regional manager. And Dwight says, assistant to the regional manager. And then Jim has this great line where he says, well, you know what, Dwight, he's your work boss, okay?
He is not your relationship boss. That's right. It's powerful. I saw two things in this scene that are great examples of stuff we've talked about on the podcast before. Let's hear him. At 13 minutes and 27 seconds, Dwight's chair does not have arms. This was the question. crap chair. Oh, the s one pass around. Yes. It's in this scene. I didn't think it ever played prominently
in a scene, but somehow before Rain started this scene, he got the crap chair and there are no arms on this chair. Oh my gosh. And it made me laugh. It brought me back because I was like, I remember when I get stuck with that chair without the arms. I remember purposely going to set before Brian and Oscar. so I wouldn't get crap chair. We just move it around to all our desks and you'd be like, oh, it really motivated you to get to set early. Also, at 13 minutes and 35 seconds, there is so clearly a faky document on Dwight's monitor and Jim's monitor. I saw that. It's also on merit of this monitor.
The same one? No, they're all slightly different, but I mean, they really look almost like a sticker. you can just tell that these computers don't really work. If you like just notice that in every single scene, it's the same faky document on these monitors. But I think especially telling is the fact that Kate is not playing solitaire in the background. Right. The scene with Jim and Dwight is going to continue. And Jim basically says, you know what, if there's a lull in conversation between you and Katie, just buy a purse.
And Dwight's like, what? I don't want a purse. Purses are for girls. And Jim says Dwight, that is not necessarily true. Do you read GQ? Because I do. And they're like many briefcases, all right? Lots of guys have them.
Well, this made me curious. What does GQ say? What is the buzz about the MERS, the man purse? Well, Ange, should we take a break? And when we come back, you'll tell us. Oh, get ready. Okay. Because when we come back, I have a lot to say about men's purses.
I have a lot of hearing about them that I want to do. So we're a good match. That sounds like a catchy phrase. I have a lot of hearing I want to do about that. We're inventing a lot of phrases that are going to catch on this week. They're all gold. All gold. We are back and Jim is really trying to pump Dwight up.
to get him, to have the confidence, to go in and talk to Katie. And he says, listen, if there's a lull in the conversation, just buy a purse. Yeah. And Dwight says, I don't want a purse. Purses are for girls. And Jim says, Dwight, that is not necessarily true. Do you read GQ? I do.
And they're like many briefcases. Lots of guys have them. Well, lady, I was curious. What does GQ say about men's purses? What do they say? I looked it up. GQ certainly has a lot of great links to great bags, and I found several articles, and I'm going to share with you the evolution of the men's purse. Well, like I said before the break, I am ready to receive this information into my ears.
There it is. Just eloquently said. So per a New York Post article written by Brooke Cato, I'll put the full article in our stories, Brooke says this, long before there were handbags or even pockets, there were girdle pouches for men. You would wear your girdle pouch. It would hold spices and money. How about that? Huh. Huh.
So men had a type of satchel that they would strap to themselves. Okay. Then per GQ magazine, later came a structural rectangular briefcase meant for carrying papers to and from work. This was during the Industrial Revolution. Then there were these certain big moments sort of. in the zeitgeis where bags were featured. For example, the satchel really expanded because of Harrison Ford's character, Indiana Jones. He has that cross-body satchel in the 80s movie. So did a bunch of men start carrying satchels to be like Harrison Ford in that movie? Yes. Wow. And then there were these moments in the
90s and early 2000s when purses kind of became a punchline, like Matt LeBlanc's character and friends, famously has this leather bag and they make fun of him for it. Okay. And then in the show Seinfeld, Jerry Seinfeld ditches his overstuffed wallet for a shoulder bag. And then in the 2009 comedy The Hangover, Zach Galfanakas sports a brown cross-body bag, much to the chagrin of his buddies. So they got made fun of a little bit. It feels like this episode falls in that time period of the 90s, early 2000s.
But then in 2018, Vogue Business says there was a debut of sporty cross-body bags from Gucci and Supreme. And all of a sudden, you saw these celebrities and athletes using them. And it really blew this up. And then I read on a website called Glossy in August of 2024 that searches for men's cross-body and carry-all bags has gone up. Are you ready for this? Okay. 900% Wow.
Yeah. I also read on several different websites where they asked men about carrying types of bags and cross-body bags and they had one common theme. They all like the functionality of it. A few mentioned that trying to fit all of their items into their pockets made their pants uncomfortable and bulky. Mm-hmm. That makes sense to me. And now with athletes carrying these bags on game days and celebrities, are carrying them on red carpets, men's bags are really taking off.
But this is like 20 years later. Yes. At this time. At this time, when this episode was written, it was very much still in the zeitgeist to make fun of it, to call it a MERS, a man purse. But that is not the case anymore. But men's purses are nothing new. Men have been carrying like these girdle pouch things for a long time. Hmm. So there you go. I say go get your bag if you want a bag.
I just want bigger pockets. I actually want to put everything in my pockets. Well, I don't want a purse. You don't want a purse. You want bigger pockets. But for people who want more than just what can fit in your pocket, go get your bag. Yeah. I guess so. Well, Dwight's going to take Jim's advice. He's going to go in and he's going to buy a purse from Katie. And then Jim is going to run over to Pam's desk and they're going to do that little thing you do where you like make up dialogue. Flirty flirt, flirt. As they're watching him through the window, they're like, oh, look, I love this. This is wonderful. They're doing that little thing.
I actually brought up part of this scene in my All About Michael Scott because it's when we find out that Michael's cell phone ring at this time is Mambo number five. Yes, this was added in the super fan episode, this flirty moment at reception with Jim and Pam is expanded. And this is when Pam tells Jim that Michael has been talking to Katie as well. Yeah. And the shot from our opening credits was taken from this scene. Oh, yeah. Of Jim and Pam at reception.
That's from this moment of them watching Dwight in the conference room. I also want to note that there's this moment in this scene when Pam mentions that his cell phone ringtone is still Mambo number five. we kind of cut to Michael in his office. It's at 15 minutes, 34 seconds, and you can really tell that that is real sunlight coming through the window, that that is not faky window that this is from the real building. Because we're in the real building. Yep. Well, now Katie is showing Pam a cute purse and Michael interrupts them and he does the Michael Snark thing again. He says to Pam, I'm sorry, are you on your lunch break or was that earlier?
Yeah. Busted. So she leaves and as she's leaving, Katie goes, come back. Was that scripted or improvised? I looked it up. It was improvised. I had a feeling. It was just really funny.
Well, now Michael tells Katie, I got to show you something. Come to my office. He bought the flipping Starbucks digital barista for $1,000. Yes. And he has a talking head where he says, coffee is the great incentivizer. Really speeds people up. He says it's not the only drug that does that back in the 80s before they knew how bad cocaine was for you, Dundra Mifflin. Man, they could really move some paper.
That made me laugh. I thought that was funny. Katie is going to get a text and she looks really bummed because her ride has bailed on her. Who is her ride? Why doesn't Katie have a car? I know. Someone dropped her off at this business park. And she didn't know anyone there.
They just dropped her off. I mean, we talked about this before. All day she needed to be in the conference room. How long does it take to sell purses to 16 people? I mean. And who dropped her off? And why won't they come pick her up? Well, I don't know.
They're not going to. But Michael is going to insist on driving her home. She reluctantly agrees. And now we get this amazing new Michael talking head, where Michael is just talking about why women find him attractive. It is so all over the place. It's brilliant. I thought we should hear it.
Why do women find Michael Scott attractive? Why are women appealed to Michael Scott? I guess because I'm an authority figure because I have a lot of power. Women are attracted to that. That's appealing to women. I think I'm a little bit of a bad boy. They're a little mystery to me.
I don't just lay it all out there. You know, you have to hold something back. I don't think I'm too shabby to look at. I wouldn't kick me out of bed for eating crackers. But I guess I think my comedy really is the, is the topper. That's the way to get in, you know? I think that's really what's saying.
Once they're laughing, that's, once they're laughing, that's 50% of them being horizontal. So not that I'm just, not that that's my, that's what I'm trying to do. But I think it helps. Kind of melts the ice. Brinks the ice. breaks the ice and melts them melts their hearts.
I feel like Michael Scott could be on our episode today. I know. With all these phrases that he's coining. I know. I looked in the script. This talking head is not in it. Nope. It is not in our candy bag alt.
Nope. I really think that this was just Steve improvising. Just riffing. They just let the camera roll. I loved it. I also did catch the boom. Really? All right.
Little boom shadow. Boom shadow. That was what we would sing on set. Dwight is now drinking his coffee with his brand new purse. This is a new scene that's in the superfan episode. Jim tells him, you know what, you should put some stuff in your purse because if she's looking, you want to make sure it looks like you're using it, right? So Dwight looks over at Katie and then starts shoving things into his purse.
19 minutes, 24 seconds. Dwight is drinking coffee, as you mentioned, out of a football mug. Yes. But not a team mug. It's just a mug with a football on it that says football. I noticed this mug a few times in season one. It is the weirdest mug. I feel like if you could recreate this mug for someone, it would make an excellent deep cut gift for an office fan.
Oh, yeah. Also, there is so much background activity. in this scene. Meredith is at the supply shelf. Stanley walks in and sits down. We all got up from our desks in season one. It's hilarious to me. We were very busy. We were. Kevin is now taking a look at the purses. He's going to try to flirt with Katie by telling her he's in a Steve Miller tribute band. He says, do you like Steve Miller? She says no. But here, we have to do it for people because it's so funny. Okay, I'll be Kevin. Okay. Do you like Steve Miller? Miller? No. Because I'm in a Steve Miller tribute. Oh. I know. It's so good. It's so good. That was an extra
scene for the super fan. Well, now Dwight and Michael are in Michael's office. They're looking at his computer. Lady, there's a moment here that I should have included in my Michael versus technology breakdown. It's so me. Oh my God. I'm just Michael Scott when it comes to my desktop. I just I need you to hear it. I should never have let the temp touches there. I had all these great icons, and now I have four folders. So it's actually better this way. No, it's not, because I could just click on the icon and then I'm on to.
Michael, could I ask you something? He had all these icons, and now he has four folders. And he doesn't know where anything is anymore. He doesn't. Yeah. And you know what my desktop looks like? I do. I do.
Mine looks like four folders. Mine is like shit everywhere. I know. Next up in the conference room, Stanley has just purchased a purse. And Michael is going to bring Katie an espresso from the machine that is an incentive prize. And Stanley's like, wait a second, Michael. Isn't that meant to be the prize for the top salesman? And Michael's like, it cleans easily.
I can clean it. Now we're going to go to the kitchen. Jim enters, asks Dwight for his stapler. Dwight says it's in my purse. Of course, everyone gets a little snicker. Well, I just love everyone just slowly looks up and reacts, but Dwight doesn't even turn around. He's just digging in the fridge. Yes.
Again, so much deep background movement back there in the annex. Devin is walking around. Everybody is in the kitchen or just behind the kitchen. Everybody just goes everywhere all at once. It's so true. Now, Michael is going to have Pam in his office. asking about his male, but what he really wants to know is how girls her age feel about futons. I couldn't get through this scene. I mean, how could you? It's so ridiculous.
Every time he said futon. Whatever this relationship is with Katie is just so crazy. First of all, it's going to give her a thousand dollar coffee maker if she took it. Yep. Give her a ride home. I don't know what happens with the futons. Yes. Of course, Pam is going to go out and tell Jim all about this conversation. They're laughing about the futon when Roy comes in. He wants to make up with Pam. We talked about this last time. He's going to tickle her into forgiving him. Yes, we discussed my dislike for tickling. Also, if I were to do what I call a cringe meter for this episode, this one would be a nine on the cringe meter. This scene? Yeah. Poor Jim. I know. They're literally almost leaning on him laughing and tickle.
Yeah. Cringe meter number nine. And then Pam has this talking head that says Jim's a great guy. He's like a brother to her. They're best friends. She really hopes he finds someone. Pam, maybe say it enough until you believe it. Yeah. Does she wish? I don't think so because he's going to find someone in a second. She's not all that happy about it. She's real sour about it. Well, Angela's in the conference room and she's looking at purses. And we talked a lot about this scene in our original breakdown. Yes, all of our dialogue between Angela and Katie's improvising the scene. We had a lot of fun. You can tell. Thank you. You guys were good together. Thank you. I actually think there's a spinoff with you, me and Amy, just like an improv show because that scene at the top was so good. Yeah. Purse girls. Come see us every Thursday night, 9 p.m. Oh, that's too late. Too late. Sorry. It's $35 to drink minimum. There is no parking. Starts at four. Dwight is watching Angela and Katie through the window and he is going to get up his nerve to go in and ask her out. But she turns him down.
She's pretty harsh. I was like, oh, made me sad. We are now going to have a Dwight talking head. It's a pretty famous Dwight talking head. He outlines what his idea of a perfect date is. Yes, of course, there's ninjas, there's knives, there's blood. There's poison, but he knew about it all along, guys. She was in on it all along.
But he knew. Oh, right. He knew she was in on it. That's right. Luan crosses twice in the background of this talking head. Creed crosses. Devin. Then at the end, Creed again.
I was just like, there's so much crossing. Also, what's really hilarious is that both Creed and Luan cross into the accounting nook by your desk, Angela, which means that they would cross there and just stand there and then come out. And cross right back. But where do they, they must have just been standing in the corner. I don't know why they're crossing to accounting. I'm in the conference room. You're with Katie trying to buy a purse.
Yeah. What are they doing at your desk? They're messing with your stuff. They're snooping around. Oh dear. Now Michael is going to ask Ryan for some help cleaning out his car. This is one of my favorite scenes. It's one of my favorite scenes of the whole series.
Blue blast. Blue is not a flavor. No. All of it. Oh, and he wants the Arctic Blast and the passenger side cup holder. Yeah. That's ready for you, Katie. This is what you're missing. I know. You don't get the convertible. You don't get the Arctic blast. You don't get the coffee maker. 25 minutes and eight seconds. Faky water bottle label and then faky blue blast label. Faky labels. Faky labels. She's tracking it. She's tracking that and who's crossing where. I am. Well, now Jim is going to go into the conference room. And what is smooth operator? Okay, Jenna F from Los Angeles wants to know how much of this was improv?
Oh, I will tell you. Per the shooting draft, this is what was scripted. Jim approaches Katie. It says he sidles up to her. He says, hi, I'm Jim. Katie says hi. The rest is improv. What?
The rest is improv until it gets to the part where he says, don't try to sell me anything. I just want to learn. Everything else is improv. This is improv. I'm Katie. Well, hi, Katie. Nice to meet you. You sit out there, don't you? I do. It's what I'm best known for sitting out there. All right. Let's talk about purses. But just talk to me. Seriously, that was all improvised. Wow. Mm-hmm. So good. So good. Jim is very smooth when he wants to be, huh? Did he flip the charm switch or what? He waited until the end of the day. Everybody was coming at her all day. He played it so cool. Yeah. We're going to go back to Michael's car.
And I love this. This is the scene where he finds all the filet of fish wrappers. The smell alike. How many filial fishes do you eat? And Michael is like, that's from a couple of months. It's like still. Ryan goes still. And then this is where we find out about his smell alike cologne.
Yes. That Ryan's like it's empty. In the straw. The soup still in the straw. How many times? have you done that? I know. You like pull it out and you wrote, I've done this so many times. Now he can throw it away. Now he can. But now this scene is expanded and Michael is going to ask Ryan to hook him up with some great music to play. I love this scene. I have talked about it. He wants Ryan's recommendations
and Ryan says do you like hip hop, indie rock, the strokes, the hives, the fleables. Oh, Michael's like yes to the fleables. Yeah. The glorbs loves them. Glorps loves them. While they're having this conversation at 26 minutes and 59 seconds, there is this angle on the parking lot and there is this brick wall behind the car. And, you know, this is because this was a real parking lot at a real building. But once we move locations, you will never see this brick wall again. And I thought it was interesting that we didn't try to recreate that. The brick wall? Yeah. We let it go. We let it go. We were like, I mean, I guess I'm not surprised because what we're. Were we going to build a brick wall?
But I don't know. Brick wall. Well, I want you to know that there was a Ryan talking head that would have come right after this scene. It's in the shooting draft. It's not in deleted scenes. It did not make it into the super fan episode. And it read simply like this. Ryan has a smug look on his face.
He looks to Cameron says, Michael's really into indie rock. He's into bands I've never even heard of. And then he laughs. Well, now. Pam is hanging out at Jim's desk. She's bored. She's like, what are you doing for the weekend? I'll tell you what he's doing this weekend. It's going out with Katie. He sure is. Oh, Pam's face. Oh, Pam's face. And guess what she's going to do? Yeah. She's going to help Roy's cousin move. Oh, the romance. Yeah, she has this line where she says, we're going to help Roy's
cousin move because Roy's got a truck. Well, this made me laugh because when Lee and I started dating, he said he always had to help people move because he had a Zuzu trooper. He was like, he was the guy with the big car. He was. He's like, it's a real thing. Yeah. It's a real thing. The person with the big car. It's true. I do remember that. I had a friend with a truck and he moved everybody. Exactly. It's so true. Well, I want to point out when Sam sort of sadly walks back to reception, there is no plant. Oh. There's no plan at reception.
No, there's not. Well, now Michael's going to have another talking head where he's talking again about being a ladies man. Wait, I love this talking head so much, lady, because this is part of this runner of Michael's desktop being messed up by Ryan. Ryan has only tried to help him clean up his computer. But now, guess what, he can't find. Can't find maps. Can't find maps. And this has now been woven into the superfan version of this talking head.
I think we should hear it. I think in order to be a ladies man, it's imperative that people don't know you're a ladies man. So I kind of play that close to the chest. Ryan, where are my maps? You know, you don't like to flaunt it. Where do I go to get maps? I mean, but it's not like I'm showing off. Ryan, what did you do to my computer?
I'm supposed to have maps, right? But where? They see me as a, as a, as a big. powerful businessman here. Kind of swaggeres around a little bit. It's really not even fair. I don't know. What can I say? Women are attracted to power.
And I think other people have told me I have a very symmetrical face. I don't know. I don't know. Maybe they're right. I don't know. I just love it so much. First of all, I love it in any kind of show or writing that you get to like watch
when there are two things happening to a person. So it's like he's trying to talk about what a great catch he is. But at the same time, he's like, where are my maps? He's getting so irritated. Well, now it's the end of the day. And here's that moment. I said Dwight goes over and gives Kelly his mini briefcase purse. And then Pam is going to apply lip gloss kind of shyly. And then the cameraman catches it and she's embarrassed. That's cringe factor 10. I so remembered doing. this scene and have you ever like had this happen before? I feel like I have this stored in my body from my youth or something where like you know you're going to see maybe a cute boy that you like
and so you put on a lipstick. Yeah. Or you put on mascara. You do something. You do something. And then to just kind of like get noticed. But then when you see yourself in the mirror, you're realize how it's just like too much and then you feel like all cringy inside. Yeah, you don't feel like you're real version of yourself. Yes. You were trying to not be you. Yes. Yes. We've all done it. Yes. Well, now everyone's leaving for the day. It's dark out. Everyone's walking to their cars at the same time. Michael's walking out with Katie and Jim. And this is when we find out that Jim is just going to give Katie a ride home after they get drinks. Yeah. And Michael's like, oh, yeah, yeah. Mm-hmm. As they're walking out. Did you hear Katie's line, which I think has to be an improv by Amy?
What, what? She goes, everyone's like, good night, good night. She goes, good night. It was nice to meet some of you. That's very funny. She was so good as Katie. Well, Jim is going to open the door for his corolla for Katie. This is more of smooth Jim. Oh, so charming. And Pam is going to sadly watch from the window of Roy's truck. Yes, the truck that we talked about the first time that David Denman and I got left in when the entire production wrapped for the day. We were still sitting there waiting to do another take.
But he's good company, so if you're going to be stuck somewhere. But the superfan episode does not end there. We end now with a Michael talking head. He is still talking about his American Way magazines. He says, did you know that when Doris Roberts is in Phoenix, she likes to eat it harder? She loves barbecue. Who knew? Yeah.
He also read a profile on Corbyn Burson. And he learned that he used to play Little League. Yeah. He also read a profile on Bronson Pinchot and his adventures in Tuscany that was very charming. He also read profiles on red buttons. Yeah. He really loves that magazine, guys. He loves it.
Well, everyone, that was the super fan episode of Hot Girl. I really loved rewatching it with all that extra footage. I really did. I know. I can't believe I'm saying this, but I think I want to watch the whole series again now. I mean, I know all of you listening have watched it so many times all the way through, but I want to do it again. Well, I feel the same way. I liked going back.
So listen, if there are. any more superfan episodes that are some of your very favorites, let us know, write to us in Dear Office Ladies. We want to know which superfan episodes or just which episodes do you love the most. We will rewatch them. And now Office Lady 6.0 is going to start its holiday break, but don't worry, second drink will continue through the holidays on Mondays. So you all have a safe and happy holidays. Please know how much we appreciate you. And we'll see you in 2025. And if you take nothing else from this episode, just remember the moral of the story is that if two things look the same, that doesn't mean that they are. And you know what?
If all else fails, blow it out the window. We'll see you next year. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman
and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.